the technology industry isn't is
primarily based in silicon valley
and most of the people are are pretty
liberal and so there
there will be sort of that that liberal
skew but it but from i'd say
most of the evolution of these big tech
companies
they saw themselves as neutral uh
platforms
uh and they they didn't see themselves
as partisans engaged in a political
battle
um they merely wanted to create the the
tools and the platforms for other people
to communicate
and i think something changed if i had
to sort of pinpoint
when it changed it would have been
around 2016
um you know when when trump got elected
i think that
a lot of big tech bought into the
argument that they had
sort of caused trump to to be elected
i'm dave rubin and joining me today is
the former co of paypal
an angel investor in such companies as
facebook uber and spacex
the founder of craft ventures and a
co-host of the all-in
podcast david sacks welcome to the
reuben report
yeah great to be here i'm glad to have
you you know when i was
looking through all your bios and
wikipedia which i'm sure is all
perfectly true and all that good stuff
there's a lot of stuff i could have
pulled there
for the bio and i was thinking for the
for my young audience watching this like
basically being part of all of those
things kind of seems like the coolest
thing
possible so how does somebody get into
all of that yeah i mean i was lucky to
graduate stanford in 1994 which was the
year before the internet really kind of
took off
and i was lucky enough to meet peter
thiel when i was there
and we collaborated together on you know
we both worked on the
the student newspaper the sort of
conservative libertarian student
newspaper that peter founded and then we
ended writing a book together
and he recruited me years later to join
paypal
and um you know i actually thought i had
missed the whole
internet thing and then i got a call
from peter in 1999 and he told me about
this company he was creating
and uh you know that that company went
on to become paypal and he recruited me
to be
the ceo so yeah that's how i got into it
yeah
do you think peter or you or alan like
did anyone realize
what any of this stuff was gonna become
or just when it's unfolding you just
kind of run with it and see what happens
you know it at the time we we sort of
knew
on it like a certain level that it was
changing the world like at paypal we had
this
user counter that would track the user
growth we called it the world domination
index
so on a certain level we kind of you
know
thought it was taking over the world but
on another level we didn't
quite you know understand it it felt a
little bit like fantasy or something
um so so yeah it was like you know
it it it definitely operated on both
levels yeah how much of paypal was just
trying to get people to
like understand you could do things
differently like i
i literally remember the first time i
saw paypal i had moved into a new
apartment with a couple roommates i was
a struggling comic i barely had any
money
and one of my roommates said to me you
got to pay me on paypal for the rent
and i i didn't even know what that meant
like the idea that i could link
a bank account to something online and i
don't even think we had wi-fi yet like
it was still
wired at all like just getting people to
like understand there's new ways of
doing things like how much of it is just
that
well a big part of it and then the other
big part of it was just making it really
easy to actually do it
so you know we it's a lot easier now we
didn't have all the tools
you know that we that we have now 20
years ago and
so just getting the product to be super
simple so you could put it in an email
address put in your credit card number
and it would
send the money and then you'd get it go
to take your bank account i mean it
sounds really easy but there's all this
friction
in the way that have to be removed and i
think part of the reason why we're
successful is we
were able just to make it like
incredibly simple
yeah so you mentioned uh the diversity
myth and i've
i've talked to peter on the show and you
guys wrote this book 1995.
in essence you you wrote this at
stanford you guys
kind of predicted everything that was
happening that's happening right now
like really
the idea that that sort of the the
diversity
of immutable characteristics would
matter more than the diversity of
thought
which we now see just rampaging through
all our businesses and institutions and
the political sphere and everything
how did you guys see it coming we had we
had been
you know writing on the the stanford
review and stanford was sort of the
epicenter that there was a famous
protest in
1988 where jesse jackson led a
letter a a mob that was chanting hey hey
ho ho western culture has got to go so
stanford was sort of the the epicenter
for for a lot of that stuff and
so we were writing about it as a student
journalist in a way and that book was
an extension of the student journalism
we had done
um you know looking back i mean i was a
teenager when
uh we wrote a lot of that i wouldn't
necessarily make all the same arguments
the same way that i did back then but i
do think
we were ahead of the curve in realizing
you know this
um this growing a liberalism you know
this this sort of political correctness
now it's you know called cancel culture
where
uh where you know we're putting
restrictions on people's ability to
speak
and to think and uh to express
themselves in ways that i think
would have been um
that that certainly you know 1960s
liberals would wouldn't have
um you know wouldn't wouldn't have
supported
and so you know i never i never
initially saw myself as a conservative i
saw myself as more of like a 1960 style
liberal
who believed in free speech and you know
a colorblind society
i i know the feeling man we're on a
similar
journey here yeah with these issues um
but yeah i mean you know it was the
illiberalism
on campus that sort of pushed me to
become
more politically aware and uh you know
and
that's what the book was about and now
really the whole country is like
um it was like andrew sullivan says we
all live on campus now
right because it's kind of funny to me
you guys were writing about this in 95
and say when i was talking about some of
this stuff
five years ago so you know 20 years
after you wrote about it
people kept saying to me no no it's just
going to stay on campuses
and when they get to the real world the
real world
will show them and uh no
those students graduated you know and uh
and they took those ideologies into the
places where where they went
and uh so you know they took them to
the you know a lot of those graduates
went off to run school boards or to run
uh you know newspapers the new york
times and
you know places like that i mean this is
it's a very elite
um uh philosophy or ideology that's
being
um imposed and it's it's coming from
places like
you know stanford and other uh ivy
league type type schools
yeah so you've been big on sort of the
three topics that at least for me at the
moment are are my big three topics which
are
are big tech covid and then california
specifically because i think there's
covet at a sort of national and
worldwide level and then california so
we'll hold that for a moment but on the
big tech
stuff you know i started talking about
free speech a couple years ago
and then there was suddenly this feeling
that we were kind of being censored but
we couldn't figure it out then we
started hearing
phrases like shadow banning and d
boosting
and algorithmic fairness all of these
things
and i think one of the things that
people wonder about is how
this all infected all of
seemingly all of the big tech companies
yeah you have any theories on where it
sort of started in there
and and how it became so inclusive
yeah well i think you know the the
technology industry isn't
is primarily based in silicon valley and
most of the people
are are pretty liberal and so there
there will be sort of that that liberal
skew but
it but from i'd say most of the
evolution of these big tech companies
they saw themselves as neutral uh
platforms
uh and they they didn't see themselves
as partisans engaged in a political
battle
um they merely wanted to create the the
tools and the platforms for other people
to communicate
and i think something changed if i had
to sort of pinpoint
when it changed it would have been
around 2016
um you know when when trump got elected
i think that
a lot of big tech bought into the
argument that they had
sort of caused uh trump to to to be
elected
or you know that that sort of
disinformation
you know had been used through their
platforms and this had resulted in
the election of trump and so therefore
they could no longer just be
neutral they would have to take
corrective measures
to prevent this uh this disinformation
and i think that was sort of the the
beginning of it
where again the the the i think
big tech sort of bought into this idea i
think they were predisposed to buying
into it because
they were liberal but they were never as
partisan
as they subsequently became over the
last few years
it's not that dissimilar from i think
what happened with the news industry you
know there were people
like brent bizzell for years who were
doing studies showing that 90 plus
percent of reporters
were liberal voted democrat and so on
but they
believed in a a code a journalistic code
of objectivity or neutrality
and somehow you know over over the last
four years trump was perceived as such a
threat
that you know the media decided that was
more important to stop
trump than to live up to the sort of
this code of of neutrality and i think
something similar happened in big tech
as well yeah has it been tough for you
as someone that
isn't purely a leftist regardless of how
you fully defined yourself but you're
not you're clearly not purely a leftist
but to be in san francisco and still be
around a lot of that i mean right now we
know that a ton of people
the whole the whole biz the whole
industry is fleeing to miami miami's
looking pretty good right now to have
some open conversations
well yeah i mean so no i mean there's
been no
reprisals or anything like that but i do
think that people feel
like they can't say you know exactly
what they think i do think that people
feel
um uncomfortable expressing a view
that's not the
prevailing you know the prevailing views
and
so for me part of the reason why i
started doing the all-in pod and started
speaking out more is just to show people
that they could speak out
um because the gap between what makes
sense and what people feel comfortable
has never been greater
i mean if you look back on 2020 i mean
just to name a few issues
i mean these protracted lockdowns that
you know aren't
substantiated by science i mean they're
just kind of crazy
the idea of defunding or abolishing the
police i mean
you can you know believe that we need to
have controls on the use of violence by
police but just to
say that we should just abolish the
police or or
um or or defund them or to empty out the
jails as a
which is happening now in in san
francisco and we'll get to your da in a
little bit don't worry about that
just for me but what struck me is not
just like that these ideas are just so
crazy and sort of off-base but just that
nobody felt comfortable
saying these things and so i felt a
little bit of an obligation to speak out
more
because you know economically i you know
if i get cancelled i'm still going to be
fine you know um i'm not
i'm in a i'm in a position where i mean
i don't know if i can be cancelled
but um but if i can i might you know
economically i'm gonna be fine so
um so i felt like we need more people to
speak up you know speak out so that
everybody feels comfortable and they
don't feel like they're just going crazy
if they're you know not in favor of of
defunding the police or something like
that
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about tech
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our tech
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics
check out our full episode playlist
they're right over here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell